our first story here Fox News has said
they will match employee donations to
satanic temple the Trevor Project
Planned Parenthood and the splc
unbelievable all the organizations of
course that we would hope Fox would be
against because they stand for all the
things that Fox's audience wants
destroyed in the United States but here
we are whistleblowers from Fox News have
revealed that the company uses an app
called Fox giving to match employee
donations to approved organizations
which again include the satanic satanic
temple the Trevor Project which by the
way for those of you have been following
the show no has a chat room portal that
they advertise to minors that allows for
you to speak to an adult about your
sexual identity and if you hit the
escape button three times it clears your
entire browser history cool is that the
one with that Daniel Radcliffe speaks
for yeah okay yeah so if that's not bad
enough of course they're also matching
donations to Planned Parenthood and the
splc they're willing to match donations
up to 1 000 so the whistleblowers took
the story to the blaze which reports
that fox is going to subsidize some of
the very activist groups that despise
and seek to ruin the Network's viewers
evidencing a complete disregard and
hatred for its core audience we've seen
a lot of shenanigans from the people
over at Fox lately them getting rid of
Tucker Carlson was certainly in my
estimation of blunder on their part I
also think it was bad for the American
people the way I've described this in
the past is that CNN tells you what
you're supposed to believe and then Fox
exists to tell you what you're allowed
to believe if you're not going to
swallow what they're trying to give you
over at CNN Fox offers you this
alternative that's still somewhat Market
safe it's still somewhat PC and they
tell you this is the outer limit this is
the boundary once you've hit this you
can't go further to the right or else
you're a nut job in a conspiracy
theorist part of the value of Tucker
Carlson on that network was that he
pushed that Overton window further to
the right they got rid of him that is
one step that Fox News has taken and
what I would argue is a long series of
steps to insult their core audience and
harm the movement what do you guys think
all right my first question is what did
fox say in response to the blaze piece
did they put out a statement did they
deny it did they confirm it I haven't
seen any comments from them yet and I
will say there are a lot of Corporations
that offer this type of match giving
right so Google did this for a long time
and I know that there were cases of
employees opting to donate to
conservative causes and Google said no
we won't do it and so for me I I can't I
don't personally know the list of Lara
Fox but I would love to see what
organizations Fox is denying if they're
saying yes to the splc if they're saying
yes to uh Planned Parenthood they're
saying yes to satanic temple who are
they also saying yes and who are they
saying no to it's just hard for me to
believe that fox would do that
particularly with an organization like
splc I mean this is an organization that
once called Dr Ben Carson a hate monger
and so I just I'm a little skeptical I
like to see what fox has said in
response because there are a lot of
people that are mad at Fox and uh they
come forward they give a story and next
thing you know people run with it so I
just I'm skeptical all the time and I'm
skeptical about this too yeah that's
fair I think that's a prudent approach
to take to to wonder what their
statement is and I guess we'll see how
they respond to this I've definitely by
been disturbed by some of what foxes
done in the past year but but I would
agree that's probably a safe course of
action and clearly I'm upset about
Tucker Carlson not being there yeah I
announced for president on April 20th
which turned out to be Tucker Carlson's
neck to the last show by the way I
started not to announce on April 20
because that's Hitler's birthday I'm a
little
suspicious about that and we started to
put it off for one week I'm happy we
didn't because then we would have been
on somebody else's show we ended up
being on the highest rated show in the
prime time so you believe that fox is
essentially it's the outer limits of
what you're allowed to to believe
publicly without being considered like
far right like yeah do not pass go do
not become oan yeah yeah well I I think
that's one way of looking at it they're
sort of uh they're conservative I think
they're probably more in line with
establishment conservatism but people
see them as safer I think so Fox as
compared to you know an organization
that you mentioned One America Network
or some of these other networks and
online Publications has somewhat uh of
an increased level of credibility in the
mainstream I would say you know Tim I
have to I have a question uh of course
do we have to question this we call them
Tim tonight
yes uh you know you know to both of my
teams the the thing is I I do feel as
though I have to raise a question of uh
uh First Amendment rights right so yeah
and I'm not an expert in this but uh if
a company offers to match your giving if
it's wrong for Google to say we won't
match your gift to a right-wing
organization we disagree with is it
wrong for Fox to say we won't uh give
money to a left-wing organization that
you you choose to pay here it is
surprising to me that someone who wants
to give money to the splc works at Fox
but you never know some people media
yeah I mean there's a lot of important
media who are on the left you know just
like there are people who work for some
left-wing organizations who are more
conservative and just don't talk about
it I would suspect it's the case that
there are left-wing people who work for
fox and aren't super open about it or
maybe they are more open about it I've
never been to their Studio what I will
say is there's two different ways to
look at your question here there's the
legal question and there's the moral
question I can't answer the legal
question uh I'm sure Larry was more
equipped to answer that one but in terms
of the moral question I don't think
there's anything wrong with fox saying
no we would be unwilling to uh match a
donation to organizations that despise
our viewers and everything we stand for
I mean but legally I'm curious when you
have to say it's a private company yeah
yeah you'll see no reason why they can't
have a policy like that we're not going
to match company match to organizations
we don't like and that assault our our
viewers yeah yeah absolutely so you
brought up a story with Google and and
you asked if it's okay in in both
circumstances I'm curious what the
Fallout ended up being for Google uh
well with Google no I
I know the story personally for some of
these employees they they battled
through and got the donations but
obviously then had a Target on their
back right they were then a band of
people who believed in the wrong
organization so it is it is a question
of what what the precautionary I I tend
to agree with you if they're a private
company perhaps they should have value
and I think it would show Integrity to
what they uh presumed to represent in in
this country of course you know I think
fox has done some some good things I
think there are things that I question
of course it is a major corporation and
I think ultimately it serves its its
bottom line which you know is is a
reality of uh of their business
um and so it's not yeah imagine being
like in an industry full of people where
you're like maybe you're like the one
right-wing guy at CNN imagine being the
one left-wing guy at Fox News you're
just you're just the one guy hanging out
there that doesn't sound like well there
are people like that I mean that's what
project Veritas found out about CNN yeah
a couple of people were on tape and they
were upset about Jeffrey Zucker and
about how every morning he would have a
nine o'clock meeting or whatever hour it
was basically telling people what to say
and this guy was ticked off about it he
said he had a personal Vendetta against
Donald Trump tell us what to say to the
exclusion of other of other issues so
there are people within probably every
organization that feels that way do you
think that the the trajectory fox has
been on where they've lost some of the
support you know since the election and
what's going on now so obviously since
Tucker has gone does that fall in line
kind of with project Veritas since the
exit of James O'Keefe where I see people
like I still follow project Veritas on
social media but I don't see the same
kind of vigor for the for the cause that
you saw there before like there it feels
like they're just they've lost the
momentum that they had before well in my
opinion it's hard to say that people
like uh Mark Levin or Sean Hannity are
not aggressive they're not passionate uh
they are but I do think Fox
underestimated how popular Tucker
Carlson was and how much he meant to the
whole organization it reminds me of when
Johnny Carson was on uh late night and
when he'd go on vacation uh The Today
Show or whatever show it was in the
morning of the Today show I would have a
lower rating oh I meant I meant more
like the the audience it's Vigor like I
don't see the same like I felt like the
support behind those organizations from
Their audience ratings stole that yeah
the ratings are down almost 50 yeah I
mean I think that is a good point for me
it's Fox is interesting for a lot of
reasons one of the things that I would
question is
um if the audience are reacting to the
content and the content is ultimately
driven by executive decisions and of
course we'd have to kind of examine
what's going on with the Murdoch family
to completely understand uh the
direction that fox is taking and I'm not
sure how to speculate on that but I know
that you know as as leadership changes
hands of course there can be questions
about the direction of the network right
um I also find that you know again I
think there's a place for conservative
media of course and of course there
should be conservative voice in
mainstream media but because we tend to
work on alternative media we work on you
know the internet emerging media
um there the thing that I love about
conservative audiences is that they are
always willing to seek new sources and I
find that to be refreshing in some ways
fox has to compete with more because we
are growing stronger than CNN's sort of
mainstream media does because I just
don't see the same parallel to what we
are building here on the left they see
they take their CNN they set it and
forget it and just use that as their
source for everything is their source of
information for everything whereas
people who are tend to be right leaning
are excited to go out and explore new
avenues of people to listen to and
totally I think Brett the miscalculation
was that fox historically they've seen
big names depart Bill O'Reilly left
train kept ongoing Megan Kelly left
train kept on going Lou Dobbs you know a
lot of people have left and nothing
happened and I think they assume that
you organization was bigger than any one
individual and they underestimated how
how big Tucker Carlson was yeah I mean
he was absolutely massive and people
really loved him part of what I valued
so much about him were the things I laid
out earlier about the fact that he was
willing to entertain and even promote
ideas that other people in the
mainstream weren't what he was saying
about January 6th and Ray Epps were
things that I was very surprised to hear
on television and about Ukraine and
about Ukraine I mean and these are
things that really lended credibility to
this narrative not just because he was
saying it on television that's huge in
terms of Optics but also because he was
supplying good evidence for this story
and so when he released the Jan six
tapes on television I thought that was a
massive victory for truth and for the
fight against the hegemonic narrative
that the left-wing media forces the
American people to stomach and so when
he left you had a lot of conservatives
saying things like ultimately this is
really good for Tucker Carlson because
he's better off without Fox and I don't
think anyone was or is doubtful that
he's going to be tremendously successful
at whatever he does exactly but what was
really sad for me was that even though I
was well aware of the fact that he'd be
successful there is something about the
credibility that television lends to a
person that makes their ideas more
palatable to the American people thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time